[Music]
did you watch the tinder slender
no but i saw your picture with it so
what's the what's the like the the okay
so you guys don't okay so here's here's
what happened it's kind of an amazing
thing
um
there's a guy so the document it's a
documentary about this guy who goes on
tinder and his tinder profile looks like
uh you know he's kind of like a
normal-ish looking guy but he's like
clearly living a cool lifestyle like
lots of travel
in different climates kind of wearing
very nice clothes that's his profile all
right so girls swipe right on him and
they start chat with him and he he
basically what he ended up doing was he
ended up conning women out of money and
it was like a ponzi scheme so what he
would do is he would meet a woman on
tinder take her out on a date
kind of wine in diner make it look like
he's this baller of a guy
and he you know was just like
like a prince out of a fairy tale he
just loves her the average looking girl
whose average job just from my average
city and then all of a sudden he's like
come on my private jet and come do this
with me and they go together and there
she's like oh my god it's all happening
i am that princess that he picked and he
cares for and so he he starts talking to
him and
his backstory is that he um
his dad owns a diamond company and he's
the son of a billionaire and if you
google you see that this guy's a son of
a billionaire so he kind of like had
created this profile around that
and um
and then you know sure enough a month in
he's like um hey you know like he's he's
like oh you know he sends a picture of
his body he's always with the bodyguard
he's like my bodyguard got attacked oh
my god she's like oh my god is he okay
he's like yeah but you know they're
telling me i can't use my credit cards
anymore because they're tracking my
location you know like these are our
enemies for our company the diamond
business is a ruthless business
and he's like uh can i borrow your
credit card for the time being while i
uh you know because i can't use mine yet
and she's like uh okay and he's like
cool just make sure you get your limits
raised because like i have business
meetings and all this stuff so these
women end up going like 150 200 000 in
debt as he racks up credit card debt
then he's like hey go get a quick loan
and send me the money i need it because
you know my enemies are after me and
he's like my enemies are after me and so
you the documentaries the first half of
the documentary is these women talk
about how they fell in love and the
second half is like
how they got conned basically and he's
like a ponzi scheme so he's well he'd
fall in love with one woman or he'd get
them to fall in love with him
get them to start giving him money and
credit cards he'd be using that to wine
and dine the next woman
and then he would be doing this with
multiple women at once telling them all
the same things and then he was living
this like extravagant lifestyle on all
these women's dime
and uh
and then you know so that's that way
that's the score of the movie quick
reaction to that and i'm gonna tell you
some other stuff well what happened to
him so how does this end it ends with he
gets exposed so the women are like oh my
god you know they they go to the credit
card company they're like look i have to
be honest like
my kind of boyfriend you know or i don't
know what's going on this is the guy
he's tricking me and like they sh he's
there can we see a picture of the guy
and he she shows a picture on her phone
and that the two like agents from like
amex or whatever just look at each other
like it's him and then she's like what
it's like we've been after this guy for
years uh he does this with tons of women
they're like there's other women he's
doing this too and so it's like they
feel cheated on plus conned and um and
so he but technically what happens is is
he breaking the law he's not breaking
the law they are giving him money
they're sending him money willingly and
they are um
you know they're giving him their credit
card and they're calling the credit card
company and saying no no it's me can you
please raise my limits yes i'm traveling
i'm in i'm i'm in ibiza right now and so
they're like uh you know you're in a
kind of a sticky spot you can't really
say he stole it you clearly gave it to
him uh in fact you kind of committed
fraud but like well whatever we'll leave
that aside but like yeah you do owe this
money like this is not
um this is not you know a stolen credit
card and so
anyways how much do you get he ends up
getting a 15 month sentence for not even
for this it's for like something else
that he did like associated with this um
he serves five months he gets off free
he's out there living he's got a new
model girlfriend he lives somewhere else
um the girls kind of like exposed him in
the press because they were like okay
look law enforcement's not doing
anything or it's gonna take too long
he's gonna keep doing this in the
meantime they go to the norwegian press
where they're from and they they they
kind of like expose it the netflix turns
it into a documentary
and uh and so the guy's still out there
and one of the things in the movie is he
goes to a plastic surgeon and he's like
i want my eyes cheekbones chin mouth all
restructured and this guy's like i'm not
gonna do this only a criminal would want
this surgery and
so he's like trying to change his face
so he could keep it going but he can't
change his face and now he's like you
know kind of like public enemy number
one but a lot of people who watch this
are like dude these girls are stupid you
yeah you were just with him for the
money and then he can't do for the money
you got what you deserve so the girls
are getting a ton of flack for it which
is really crazy that's that's that's
dumb
but i was just thinking what a waste of
talent by this guy
yeah like that's pretty amazing
it's like it's like a you know what's
funny is like leonardo dicaprio played
the same character and catch me if you
can and it was awesome yeah he became
like when i see this guy i want to punch
him in the face yeah exactly
that was the problem it was a
documentary instead of
a movie about the con man itself where
you sort of fall in love with this
smooth guy uh yeah if a different if if
like a lovable if like if like matt
damon played him i would be all about it
but
super punchable face this guy
yeah um and the memes are just amazing
uh around well i saw the meme with you
with your face on it yeah yeah yes i had
somebody i was like hey photoshop my
head onto
onto this photo where it looks like i'm
with the guy and i just tweeted out like
i'm with my sister's new boyfriend like
is he american
no this guy's israeli
uh dude screw this guy man i i i'm happy
they made a documentary about him how
did he get all the uh so he's in a
private jet in a bunch of these pictures
how did he get that
because he's using the previous woman's
money to fund his his lifestyle so he
would fly private yeah yeah so he's
actually flying private i don't know all
the time but at least some of the time
and uh it was just really wild in fact a
lot of the numbers don't make sense like
he must have been running this on like
tons of women at once to fund this
lifestyle because these like the jets
and the stuff that he was doing like
okay he called this woman out of 80
grand but 80 grand funds like one month
of this lifestyle you know like that's
not very long so he must have had a lot
of people at the same time or
the documentary's a little inaccurate i
don't know but how much money did he get
they said that he had conned women out
of millions of dollars uh over over time
um they didn't say exactly how much they
don't know you know how much of it what
was there but
but i just feel like he did this all
wrong like if you're gonna do all this
effort
you gotta be more intelligent right like
okay what could he have done um
could have just married rich could've
just seemed rich married rich divorced
took half right like that that would
have worked uh wait wait you know put
more wood behind fewer arrows here and
he could have just caught one very
wealthy person if he really wanted to do
this that's my first critique of him
uh my second critique of him is
bro all this money to just party
partying's exhausting like why he just
wanted to fly private and go to these
clubs and do table service like
you know
you couldn't pay me to do that i don't
know
you got to diversify your assets dog
yeah you should uh you should
own some crypto like buy something buy
buy a home do do something with this
money you just blew all the money on
overpriced you know like bottle service
at the club like wow all right that's
critique number two
um
number three
go b to b bro corporate swindling would
have worked way better so you know he
could have been like you you heard about
the guy who just started sending
invoices to microsoft and apple and
stuff just got paid like millions of
dollars just
he was just sending an invoice to
accounts payable or whatever and uh and
then they would just pay some of the
invoices
like ap at microsoft.com yeah and he was
like he's like hey you know this is for
the uh blah blah and like and then they
went back and they're like what the hell
is this who is this vendor that we paid
1.1 million dollars to this year like
nobody knows who this is i don't think
that's illegal either
uh i think it is because he was like you
know uh well whatever they were going
back after them you know these companies
a lot of money so that's the downside of
going b2b i feel like there could have
been a b2b way of doing this
should have actually just started a
diamond company could have made a lot
more money if you're this good at
getting women's emotions tied up in your
your lifestyle just actually sell the
diamonds it would have worked
use their money to fund a diamond
company that actually could have worked
this guy needs to be needs to be on the
facebook ad manager instead of tinder
that's my and i'm just make your tweet
i'm looking at them now the all those
these women who we scammed like a lot of
them look like models like he was
killing it also like you forgot the
other option which is like just marry
one of these ladies if they're rich
enough to like if they're these
beautiful women who could wire them 200k
like
i don't know man bro maybe you got to
keep her well in this case he's like he
was telling him like go take like a kind
of like a
collateralized loan or a payday loan and
like super high just don't worry he's
like i'm gonna wire your money back in
four days and then he would like not
wire them back and then they'd be like
hey did you wire the money he's like oh
sorry they are like the bank was closed
okay and then he would like show them a
statement he'd be like i sent it should
arrive in a couple days
she's like hey it hasn't arrived yet
what's going on like the interest is
building up on this like flash loan you
had me take
he's like oh my god let me call the bank
another two days go by he's like called
the bank they said this thing got frozen
i gotta i gotta deal with this i'm so
sorry here uh you know i'm gonna send
you one of my watches in the meantime
you could just sell this watch is worth
a hundred thousand dollars sends them a
fake watch and you just buy time doing
that it's like these women didn't have
the money but like i think he could he
could have totally
gone for a richer woman
and then been like you know what baby
like
i love you i'm not going to make you
sign a prenup you know me i'm a
billionaire uh i come from this lineage
but i'm not my dad says sign up prenup
i'm not gonna do it and then she would
feel a little bit of pressure and be
like okay i guess i can't really ask him
for a peanut anyways this guy's richer
than me all right i guess i also won't
that would have been a more effective
con if this guy were in jail do you
think he'd be popular or hated
i think popular sadly you think popular
i think i think popular i could see this
going either way man i could see this
i could see this going either way i
think like dude
in prison would he like all right so
bernie madoff i heard in prison was like
a god which i get i get that you know
like he could teach people how to like
corner like the chocolate chip or the
chocolate uh hot chocolate market like
in prison like he could like you know or
he could like you know dominate the
commissary and like teach you about
markets i get that and also there was it
wasn't a violent crime so no
children or women would hurt like this
guy is he i would see this guy being
unpopular uh
i don't know that's a good he's got kind
of like a douchebag aurora to him so
that's the problem that's that's where
he's gonna get in trouble but uh
bro the swindler this window would do
well in prison
i guess i'll watch it how many episodes
he's not in prison he's out and about
he's living a nice life right now i'll
screw this guy man and he sold a couple
million dollars
yeah i think i think about i think this
documentary is good punishment though
that's fair i'm okay with you not
serving time and you have this
documentary
our buddy jack butcher pointed something
out that i was like oh wait a minute
that's true he's like yo netflix is
gonna make a lot of money off this
documentary pay off these women's debts
they have like a gofundme going it's
like yo netflix you need to pay off this
woman's 200 000 debt that's true you did
well on this documentary so that's the
that's the real call out here netflix
cancel netflix if they don't pay off
these women's debts
that's a no-brainer you don't think
they're going to
well nobody said anything these women
are doing interviews everywhere there's
a gofundme out there i feel like i feel
like they could have said or they're
just you know swindling people one good
thing that you know we didn't make a lot
of money off this but netflix actually
generously did agree to pay off the debt
you know uh blah blah blah that i feel
like that story should have come out if
they did it if they didn't then fire
your either fire your pr person netflix
or
pay off this pay these debts
[Music]